Why are so many autistic females overlooked, misdiagnosed or diagnosed too late? Today we are uncovering the hidden stories behind any statistics, exploring the unique ways autism presents in girls, and why traditional frameworks often fail them. If you've ever wondered how masking, stereotypes and societal expectations impact autistic girls, then stay tuned because this conversation is essential. Hi, welcome along to the aspiring psychologist podcast. I am Dr. Marianne and I'm a qualified clinical psychologist. Now today we are meeting someone who works as an assistant psychologist and who has a sister who is autistic herself and was diagnosed later than would have been ideal for her. Let's dive straight in
为什么那么多自闭症女性被忽视、误诊或诊断过晚？今天我们将揭开任何统计数据背后的隐藏故事，探讨自闭症在女孩身上表现出的独特性，以及为什么传统框架常常无法帮助她们。如果你曾好奇伪装、刻板印象和期许如何影响自闭症女孩，请继续收听，因为这次对话至关重要。嗨，欢迎来到“有志心理学家播客”。我是玛丽安博士，我是一名合格的临床心理学家。今天我们要见一位担任助理心理学家的嘉宾，她的姐姐本身患有自闭症，而且确诊的时间比理想中要晚。让我们直接切入正题
but please if you do find this content helpful please do like, please do comment it is the kindest thing you can do for any podcaster and please feel free to share the episode with people as well, perhaps with your colleagues, perhaps with your friends, perhaps with your family. Whether that is a YouTube episode or the MP3 version 2. I hope you find it so useful and I will look forward to catching up with you on the other side. Hi, just want to welcome along our guest for today, Hannah who is an assistant psychologist. Hi Hannah. Hi Marianne, thank you so much for having me.
但请注意，如果您确实觉得这些内容对您有帮助，请点赞，请留言，这是您对任何播客创作者能做的最贴心的支持，也请随时与他人分享这集节目，也许是您的同事，也许是您的朋友，也许是您的家人。无论是YouTube节目还是MP3版本。希望您觉得这集节目非常有用，我期待在节目结束后与您交流。嗨，我想欢迎我们今天的嘉宾，汉娜，她是一名助理心理学家。嗨，汉娜。嗨，玛丽安，非常感谢邀请我来。
Oh well thank you for being here and thank you for pitching your episode to me as well. So this is of course close to your heart but you really wanted us to open up the narrative around autistic spectrum disorder diagnoses or autistic spectrum condition diagnosis, specifically in females and how that might look different for females compared to males or you know let's open this up to genders rather than necessarily pigeonholing them but your experience is that your sister has a diagnosis of autism and so you've kind of learned quite a lot about those differences really haven't you Hannah? Absolutely yes and it's very apparent that both within society and with the world of psychology there is this stereotyping of what autism should look like and it's based
哦，不客气，谢谢你能来到这里，也谢谢你向我推荐这集节目。所以这当然是你非常关心的话题，但你真的很想让我们开启关于孤独症谱系障碍诊断或孤独症谱系条件诊断的新叙事，特别是在女性群体中，以及女性与男性相比可能会有什么不同，或者你知道的，让我们把这个话题扩展到性别，而不一定是生硬地归类，但你的经历是你的姐姐被诊断出患有孤独症，所以你其实已经对这些差异有了相当多的了解，对吧，汉娜？完全是的，很明显，无论是在社会中还是在心理学世界里，都存在着一种关于孤独症应该是什么样子的刻板印象，而它是基于
upon a lot of research with mostly male participants so there's been quite a huge lack of understanding of how autism actually presents in girls or people who are not male. Yeah absolutely and a book that I was recently involved with called An Autistic Anthology is looking at mental health professionals who have an autism diagnosis or who understand themselves to fit within an autism framework. And actually, I would say the majority of the people in that book are female, which I think it shows us that we're moving in a very, you know, neuroinformed direction. Certainly very different than when I was an aspiring psychologist and, you know, I was doing some reading around the topic when I was a
大部分以男性参与者为主的研究，因此对于孤独症在女孩或非男性群体中实际是如何表现的，存在着相当大的理解缺乏。是的，完全是这样。我最近参与的一本书叫做《自闭症文集》（An Autistic Anthology），它关注的是拥有自闭症诊断，或者认为自己符合自闭症框架的心理健康专业人士。事实上，我要说这本书里的大多数人都是女性，我认为这向我们表明，我们正朝着一个非常具有神经多样性知情意识的方向前进。当然，这与我当年的经历非常不同。当我是一名有志成为心理学家的人，并且在
trainee and the book Asper Girls by Rudy Simone is a really, really interesting read. But being able to share that knowledge with parents in CAMS services was really powerful actually and really helped the validation and to kind of, yeah, to know how to optimally support either yourself to thrive or someone in your family, in your work group, in your friendship circle. It's a really, really important conversation to have, Hannah. Absolutely, definitely. And I think some of the very real problems with that stereotyping is focused on those diagnostic problems. So there's a massive underdiagnosis where boys are currently four times more likely to receive a diagnosis than girls. And around 80 percent of autistic girls are first misdiagnosed with things such as anxiety or personality disorders, depression, ADHD, things that aren't quite exactly what they're struggling with.
当实习生时阅读过鲁迪·西蒙（Rudy Simone）的《阿斯伯格女孩》（Aspergirls）这本书真的是一本非常非常有趣且值得一读的书。但能够与儿童和青少年心理健康服务（CAMHS）的家长们分享这些知识其实非常有力量，并且真正有助于获得心理验证，并某种程度上，是的，知道如何以最佳方式支持你自己蓬勃发展，或者支持你家庭、工作小组、朋友圈中的某个人。这是一个非常非常重要的话题，汉娜。完全是的，当然。我认为这种刻板印象带来的一些非常现实的问题集中在那些诊断问题上。所以目前存在大规模的诊断不足，男孩获得诊断的可能性是女孩的四倍。大约80%的自闭症女孩最初被误诊为焦虑症、人格障碍、抑郁症、多动症等并非她们真正苦恼的问题。
So they don't receive that support in the correct time. And that, of course, leads to late diagnosis, which is a huge problem because girls are getting diagnosed in their teens or even into adulthood, whereas boys are, on average, diagnosed around age five. So there are very real impacts of that stereotyping and that lack of knowledge that we need to address really. Absolutely and if people are like oh you know why would they be getting alternate
因此她们没有在正确的时间得到这种支持。当然，这导致了晚确诊，这是一个巨大的问题，因为女孩们在十几岁甚至成年后才被确诊，而男孩平均在五岁左右就被确诊。因此，这种刻板印象和缺乏知识会产生非常现实的影响，我们需要真正去解决这个问题。完全是这样。如果人们觉得“哦，天哪，为什么她们会得到替代诊断？”
diagnosis and you know just to speak to that point really it's that people who have difficulties that fit within an autism spectrum diagnosis really might struggle with a number of areas. For example, they're more likely to end up with depression, with anxiety, more likely to kind of sometimes drink more alcohol units than someone who doesn't have those difficulties. And so it's those years of trying to fit yourself into environments that aren't necessarily helping to fit around you. You know, you're having to do all of that amending, all of that amelioration, which is very, very difficult and can lead to kind of symptoms of autistic burnout as well. So,
而且就这一点而言，实际上是说，符合孤独症谱系诊断困难的人可能确实在许多领域都有所挣扎。例如，他们最终患上抑郁症、焦虑症的可能性更高，有时比没有这些困难的人摄入更多的酒精单位。因此，正是这些年试图将自己塞进不一定适合你的环境中。你知道，你不得不做所有这些调整，所有这些改进，这非常非常困难，也可能导致自闭症职业倦怠的症状。所以，
you know, that might help people understand why people are ending up with other diagnoses when in actual fact, like you say, you know, if they've been understood within that framework, within that lens and helped to understand themselves from a much younger age, perhaps like their male counterparts, just how much of an opportunity that would have been for them. Absolutely, and I think it's very important to talk about autistic masking because it is seen to be more prevalent in girls. So we think about what messages are these young girls receiving from society that they have to change or hide parts of themselves in order
你知道，这或许能帮助人们理解为什么人们最终会得到其他诊断，但实际上，就像你所说的，如果能在那个框架、那个视角下去理解他们，并帮助他们从更小的年纪就像他们的男性同伴一样去认识自己，那对他们来说将是多大的机遇啊。绝对是的，我认为讨论自闭症伪装非常重要，因为它在女孩中更为普遍。所以我们思考这些年轻女孩从社会中接收到了什么样的信息，即她们必须改变或隐藏自己的部分，以便
to fit in and be accepted. And then the impact that that's then having on their mental health as well. So without being diagnosed, they're receiving this message that it's not okay to be who they are. And there's so much trauma associated with that. So I like to think of masking as a trauma response
融入并被接纳。然后，这反过来又对她们的心理健康产生了影响。因此，在没有被诊断的情况下，她们接收到的信息是：做自己是不可以的。这其中夹杂着太多的创伤。所以我喜欢把伪装看作是一种创伤反应，
because they're responding to these very negative messages that they are receiving about who they are and whether or not that's okay. And I think as a society we really need to work to overcome this because it's not okay that these people are, these children are receiving these messages around what they should or shouldn't be like and that they feel as though they can't just be who they are. I can speak from experience that when my sister was diagnosed, the difference between her presentation before diagnosis compared to after, because she was able to unmask,
因为她们是在对她们所收到的关于自己是谁以及这是否可以的那些非常负面的信息做出反应。我认为作为一个社会，我们真的需要努力克服这一点，因为这些人、这些孩子正在接受关于他们应该或不应该是什么样的信息，并且他们觉得自己不能只是做自己，这是不行的。我可以从经验中说，当我姐姐被确诊时，她确诊前后的表现有很大不同，因为她能够卸下伪装，
she was almost a completely different person. The way that she spoke, her tone, the way that she used language, the fact that she was able to start stimming, and these were behaviors that we hadn't seen before. It's masking can have such a huge impact and it takes up so much energy and so much time and it does lead to burnout and then you have all of the trauma associated with that which then could lead to things like emotionally unstable personality disorder which is a trauma driven
她简直判若两人。她说话的方式、语调、语言使用的习惯，以及她开始能够进行自我刺激行为（stimming），这些都是我们以前没见过的行为。伪装会产生如此巨大的影响，它消耗了这么多的精力和时间，并且确实会导致倦怠，然后你就会遇到与此相关的所有创伤，而这反过来又会导致诸如边缘型人格障碍（情不稳定型人格障碍）之类的问题，这是一个由创伤驱动的
disorder and then you have lots of comorbidities that come into play. And there's a huge conversation definitely to be had around masking and the impacts of that and what messages are we as a society giving to members of the autistic community? Yeah, absolutely. And I think it's probably worth us saying, in case anyone is unsure, your sister's given us permission to talk about her. We're not naming her, we're not using her photos, but we're talking about your experiences of being her sister and kind of helping to advocate but also helping others to understand what autism is and how that looks in girls. So, yes, thank you to your sister as well. Absolutely. Some of the main differences that I see in my sister
障碍，然后你就会遇到很多并发症。关于伪装以及它的影响，还有我们作为社会究竟在向自闭症社群的成员传递什么信息，绝对有很多值得探讨的地方。是的，完全是这样。我想我们或许应该说明一下，以防有人不确定，你姐姐已经授权我们谈论她。我们没有透露她的名字，也没有使用她的照片，但我们正在讨论你作为她的姐姐的经历，以及在帮助发声的同时，也帮助他人理解什么是自闭症以及它在女孩身上是如何表现的。所以，是的，也要谢谢你的姐姐。绝对是的。我看到的我姐姐身上的一些主要差异，
compared to what the stereotypical view of autism is would be over-compliance, the being labeled as quiet, shy, and selectively mute, having lots of anxiety and masking. These are traits that I associate as being part of that female autism narrative which are often left out of the primary conversation around what autism should look like and these are traits that need to be recognised and spoke about more I
与自闭症的刻板印象相比，包括过度顺从、被贴上安静、害羞和选择性缄默的标签、有大量的焦虑以及伪装。这些都是我将其与女性自闭症叙事联系在一起的特征，而这些特征往往被排除在关于自闭症应该是什么样的主要讨论之外，我认为这些特征需要得到更多的认可和讨论。是的，所以人们观看这个视频可能有各种各样的原因。我们可能会接触到那些正在想自己是否能更好地理解自己或寻求诊断的人。我们可能会接触到那些开始对自己的孩子，或者有时甚至是他们的兄弟姐妹或父母产生疑问的家长。你知道，有人偶然发现这集节目（无论是在YouTube上还是作为MP3）可能有很多原因。但是，如果有人，例如，了解到他们的孩子是女性，并且他们正试图抚养她，但开始注意到，也许在学校里，她并没有像
think. Yeah so people might be watching this video for all kinds of reasons actually. We might be reaching people themselves that are wondering whether they might be able to understand themselves or pursue diagnosis. We may be reaching parents of people who are starting to have questions around their children or maybe sometimes you know their siblings or you know their parents. You know there's many reasons why someone might have stumbled across this episode, either on YouTube or as an MP3. But if someone, for example, understands their child to be female and they're trying to parent them but are starting to notice, maybe in school, they're not thriving in the way that
他们认为的那样茁壮成长。也许有伪装在发生，也许当他们回到家时，因为筋疲力尽，他们真的会有很强烈的情绪崩溃。老师们可能会看到什么样的情况？家长们在另一端又可能会看到什么样的情况？汉娜，你能为我们简单介绍一下吗？当然，所以在学校里，伪装是很典型的，她们可能想躲在教室的后面，可能会很安静。老师通常会说
they think they are capable of doing. Maybe there's masking going on, maybe when they're getting home they're really having kind of a strong emotional fallout kind of from exhaustion. What kind of things might teachers be seeing? What kind of things might parents be seeing at the other end? Could you talk us through that a little bit Hannah? Absolutely, so during school it's quite typical to mask and they might then want to hide at the back of the class, they might be quite quiet. The typical thing teachers would say
她们教起来很高兴，但需要多发言。然后当她们回到家时，这一切都变了。她们卸下了伪装，也许在家里的声音会大一点，而家庭成员无法理解为什么她们在学校里不怎么说话，而且看起来那么失调和紊乱，或者她们可能会退缩到自己的房间里，产生相反的效果，几乎退缩到自己内心，变得很安静，只是独自坐着，几乎从
is that they're a delight to teach, but they need to speak up more. And then when they get home, all of that changes. They unmask, maybe they're a bit louder at home and family members can't understand why then they're not speaking so much at school and they seem so dysregulated and disrupted or they might just retreat into the room and have the opposite effect where they almost retreat into themselves and they're just quiet and they can just sit with themselves and almost recover from
为了表现得正常，她们那天不得不经历的一切中恢复过来，而这甚至本不应该是她们必须做的事情。是的，完全是这样。通常，当我们与家长甚至是自闭症患者周围的成年人合作时，我们会想，实际上，你创造了一个如此可爱的家，让他们能够真正做自己，并感到舒适地卸下伪装，甚至展示一些
everything that they've had to go through that day just to try and present normally, which is something that they shouldn't even have to do. Yeah, absolutely. And often when we're working with parents or even adults who are around people with autism, it's thinking about, well, actually, it's really wonderful that you've created such a lovely home where they're able to really be themselves and to feel comfortable to kind of do that unmasking and to maybe show some
他们的挫折感，这真的很棒。也许他们一整天都在压抑着，但事实上，一旦他们回到家，他们的耐受窗口就会大大缩减，从而变得更容易产生反应。我知道要将这视为一种优势真的很难，因为家长会觉得，好吧，学校里的所有人都在享受她最好的一面，而我只得到了烧焦的残渣。但实际上，我想这是在赋能人们，让他们或许能够考虑在不同的环境中保持更一致的自我，以及这是否感觉良好。我们当然在努力教育世界
of their frustrations. Maybe they've been keeping a lid on it all day, but actually as soon as they get home, their kind of window of tolerance is that much more reduced that they're going to be more reactive. And I know that's really tricky to think about that as a strength because parents are like, well, all of their people at school are getting the best of them and I'm just getting the kind of burnt ends. But actually, I guess it's empowering people to be able to perhaps think about being a more consistent self across the settings and whether that feels okay. And we're certainly trying to educate the world
这没有什么不对。也许并不需要时时刻刻都进行伪装。绝对是的。当她们能够卸下伪装时，正是她们感到最舒适的时候。所以她们能在家里做到这一点，显然是一个优势。这意味着她们能够卸下伪装，而这正是她们感到最舒适的时候，所以她们能在家里做到这一点，显然是一个优势。这意味着她们感到舒适，并且家长们创造了一个足够有同理心的环境，让她们觉得能够做到这一点。所以这绝对是一个优势。唯一的缺点是，她们无法在户外或学校里做到这一点。
that that is okay. Maybe masking isn't needed all of the time. Absolutely, yes. When they're able to unmask, it's when they feel most comfortable. So the fact that they can do that at home is obviously a strength. It means that they're able to unmask it's when they feel most comfortable so the fact that they can do that at home is obviously a strength. It means that they're comfortable and the parents have created a compassionate enough environment that they feel able to do that. So it's definitely a strength. The only disadvantage then is the fact that they're not able to do that outside of the home or at school.
这更多地与社会对自闭症的看法有关。我觉得一旦人们有了诊断，对这些行为就会有更多的理解和同情，并且以某些方式行事也会变得更容易被接受，所以在确诊之前，伪装肯定会让人感觉更多，我猜个体会觉得为了融入集体，他们需要做更多的伪装，如果他们不明白自己为什么与众不同，这会让人感到非常不知所措，而陪伴他们度过这一过程，并剖析他们对自己的一些负面叙事，理解这些叙事为什么存在，这绝对不是他们的错，他们被告知不应该成为自己这绝对不是他们的错，并理解这不是我们支持的叙事。
And that's more to do with the way society perceives autism. I feel once people have the diagnosis there's a lot more understanding and compassion towards these behaviours and it's a bit more acceptable to act in certain ways so prior to diagnosis masking can definitely feel a lot more I guess the individual will feel that they need to do that more in order to fit in if they don't understand why they are different and that can feel very overwhelming and just being there to support them through that and through unpicking some of these negative narratives that they have about themselves and understanding why those exist and it's not their fault that they're being told that they shouldn't be who they are, it's absolutely not their fault and understanding that that's not a narrative that we're going to support.
是的，请问你姐姐确诊时多大？是的，她当时13岁，所以她是晚确诊的。在此之前，她被诊断出患有焦虑症和选择性缄默症，所以精神健康专业人员认识到出了问题的事实是——她有选择性缄默，她很焦虑，但他们没有将她转诊去确诊。这些事情被漏掉并发生误诊是非常普遍的。老实说，这让我很生气，因为精神健康专业人员没有认识到这些是女孩患自闭症的症状，我们需要尽早将更多的女孩转诊以确诊，而不是等到她们精疲力竭或身体上无法应对时才去处理，因为事情已经发展到了我姐姐
Yeah, can I ask how old your sister was when she was diagnosed? Yes, so she was 13, so she was late diagnosed and prior to that she had been diagnosed with anxiety and selective mutism, so the fact that mental health professionals are recognising something is wrong, she is selectively mute, she is anxious, but they're not referring her for a diagnosis. It's so common for these things to be missed and for misdiagnosis to occur. So it makes me quite angry to be honest that mental health professionals are not recognising that these are symptoms of autism in girls and that we need to be referring more girls for diagnosis sooner rather than waiting until they reach burnout or that they physically can't cope because it got to the stage where my sister
在学校里真的非常非常挣扎，有些事情真的必须落实到位，而晚确诊的影响意味着她无法转学到一所特殊学校，因为她没有那个标签，尽管主流环境并不适合她，她苦苦挣扎却无法跟上，她产生的问题之一就是逃学，因为对于一个神经多样性的人来说，这是一个非常具创伤性的环境。因此，她某种程度上被强行留在那个环境中，因为她被诊断出了一个不合适的标签。这恰恰证明了为什么尽早而不是推迟识别这些事情是如此重要。
was really, really struggling in school and something really needed to be put in place and the impacts of that late diagnosis meant that she was not able to transition to a specialist school because she did not have that label, even though the mainstream environment was not appropriate for her, she was struggling and she wasn't able to keep up and one of the things she developed was school avoidance because it's just such a traumatic environment to be in as a neurodiverse person. So the fact that she was kind of forced into that environment because she was diagnosed with an inappropriate label. It just demonstrates why it's so important to recognise these things sooner rather than later.
是的，完全是这样。当我在CAMHS工作时，你经常会看到的是，在小学阶段一切都进展得很顺利，但当你进入七年级时，突然之间你必须承担更多的责任。你必须学会自己应对。环境往往变得更加嘈杂。你必须记得在不同的日子带上所有不同的零碎物品。你必须学会应对有时比你大得多、
Yeah absolutely and when I was working in CAMS what you'd often see is is things went really well in primary school but then when you get to moving into year seven suddenly you've got to have more accountability. You've got to kind of navigate yourself. The environments often tend to be a lot noisier. You're having to remember to take all of your different bits and pieces on different days. You're having to cope around sometimes much bigger,
高得多的人。有很多人挤来挤去。走廊非常拥挤。有时它真的开始显现出来，真的开始让人觉得到了七年级及以后，事情几乎要分崩离析了，这可能真的非常困难，因为老师们或许是看着这个孩子从四岁长大，也许在同一所学校里和他们一起成长，并且真正理解了如何帮助这个年轻人发挥出最好的一面。然后，你知道的，他们去了中学，你失去了这一切。你得从头开始，也许受到的关照更少，调整也更少。
taller people. There's lots of jostling. The corridors are really busy. Sometimes it really starts to, really starts to become apparent that actually the wheels almost begin to fall off at year seven and beyond and that can be almost really difficult because the teachers perhaps have grown up with the child from being age four and have grown with them in perhaps in the same school and have really understood how to help get the best out of this young person. And then, you know, they go to secondary school and you don't have any of that. You're starting from scratch and perhaps there's less consideration, there's less adjustment.
你只能顺应通用的规章制度。不知不觉中，这是一个非常艰难的环境。我再次回想起我在CAMHS工作的时光，人们会开始，就像你说的，开始逃学，如果他们需要去找老师谈论某事，那会让他们觉得是一件非常非常不可能做到事情，并且会经过大量的练习和排练，被渲染成一件感觉不可能完成的、非常非常大的事情。感觉就像是用错误的装备去爬山。有时甚至以自残和住院治疗告终。
You're having to just kind of run with what the generic provision is. And before you know it, it's a really difficult environment to be in. And I'm again reflecting on my time working in CAMHS, but people would kind of start to, like you say, start to school avoid, start to really struggle if they needed to go and speak to a teacher about something, that would feel like a really, really impossible thing to do and would be so practiced and rehearsed and kind of made to be this really, really big thing that felt impossible. It felt like trying to climb a mountain, you know, in just with the wrong equipment. And sometimes ended in self-harm and ended in inpatient admission.
在那个时候，我们会想，哦，我不知道你是否曾经考虑过，你知道，你的女儿或你自己，你知道，可能患有自闭症。然后确诊可能会发生。但是，如果这一切发生得像你所说的那样年轻，我们错过了所有的痛苦，那会有什么样的机遇呢？绝对是的，这也是自闭症社群成员的自残和自杀率如此之高的原因之一。我遇到过的一项研究表明，自闭症患者死于自杀的可能性是普通人口的七倍，这是一个巨大、巨大的差异。
And at that point, we'd be like, oh, I wonder if actually you've ever considered whether, you know, your daughter or yourself, you know, might be autistic. And then the diagnosis might happen. But like, what are the opportunities if this happens, like you say, at such a younger age that we miss out all of that distress? Absolutely, and this is one of the reasons why the self-harm and suicide rates are so high for members of the autistic community. One study that I came across suggested that people with autism were seven times more likely to die by suicide than the general population and that is a huge, huge difference.
意识到这些人在经历什么，真的让人感到非常沮丧，这不是他们的错，鉴于我们在精神健康研究方面取得的进展，这本不应该发生。这是本应得到解决的事情。这是精神健康专业人员应该了解的事情，而它正导致自杀和自残等事情的发生。而且我们谈论的也是儿童，
It's so disheartening to realise what is happening to these people and it's not their fault and it's something that shouldn't be happening given the advancements that we've had in mental health research. This is something that really should have been tackled. This is something that mental health professionals should know about and the fact that it's leading to things such as suicide and self harm. And these are children we're talking about as well,
不仅仅是成年人。这绝对是我们需要更多地讨论并对之培养更多同理心的事情。是的，这真的很重要，这些都是必须进行的对话，每一个生命、每一个人都很重要。请问你姐姐现在多大？她现在17岁。所以通常在17岁时，一个人应该在预科（sixth form）学习，他们已经度过了GCSE考试。你姐姐也是这样吗？
not just adults. It's definitely something that we need to be talking more about and fostering more compassion towards. Yeah, it really it matters and they're important conversations to have and every life, every person matters. Can I ask how old your sister is currently? She's 17 now. So typically at age 17 someone would be in kind of sixth form, they've come out the other side of their GCSEs. Is that the case for your sister?
不，正如我之前提到的，我姐姐转到了一所她感到挣扎的主流高中，然后在她确诊后，我们设法把她转到了一所特殊学校，但由于她在主流学校经历的所有创伤，她仍然在逃学，即使在特殊学校里她也无法应对。因此，她随后转入了家庭学校教育（homeschooling），即使是这样，即使在一个她熟悉的环境中面对一个不熟悉的人，对她来说仍然是非常不知所措的。
No, so as I mentioned previously my sister was transitioned to a mainstream high school that she struggled with and then we managed to move her to specialist school once she had her diagnosis, but because of all the trauma she experienced through the mainstream school, she was still avoiding, she was still unable to cope even in a specialist school. So she was transitioned then to homeschooling and she still finds even that, even being around one person who's unfamiliar in an environment that she's familiar with, it's still very overwhelming for her.
所以她在接受家庭教育，但她目前没有参加任何考试，因为那会——那实在是有点勉强。所以我们推迟了一年，她本该在今年夏天参加考试的——所以我们目前推迟了，这不是我们正在考虑的事情，因为它不适合她。但她正在以其他方式坚持学习。因此，我姐姐的优势之一是她非常擅长与动物相处，她真的非常非常喜欢骑马。
So she's being homeschooled, but she is not going for any exams at the moment because that would be that would just be a bit much. So we've delayed a year she would be taking her exams this summer so we we've delayed that at the moment that's not something that we're considering because it's not something that's appropriate for her but she is persisting with education in other ways so one of my sister's strengths is that she's amazing with animals and she really, really enjoys horse riding.
所以她每周去好几次，她还在学习马厩管理。所以她正在学习如何照顾马匹，如何给它们清理，如何喂养它们。她太棒了。她可以看一眼一马，准确地告诉你它是什么品种，毛色叫什么名字，以及它需要吃什么食物。绝对通过看一眼就能知道所有事情。她在这方面太棒了。告诉你它是什么品种，毛色叫什么名字，以及它需要吃什么食物，绝对
So she goes several times a week and she's learning also stable management. So she's learning how to take care of horses, how to clean them, how to feed them. And she's amazing. She could look at a horse, tell you exactly what breed, the name of its coat and what food it needs to eat. Absolutely everything just by looking at it. She's amazing with that. tell you exactly what breed, the name of its coat and what food it needs to eat, absolutely
通过看一眼就能知道所有事情。她在这方面太棒了。所以这是我们正在探索的另一条更适合她的途径。我认为在教育自闭症患者时，重要的一点是，主流的、传统的参加考试的方式实际上可能并不适合他们，这没关系。找到适合他们的方法是很好的，因为很有可能他们实际上无法以传统意义上的方式工作，因为在我的姐姐的情况下，这会让她不知所措，无法应付。所以，某种她可以与动物一起工作的方式——她最喜欢的是马，她其实也很喜欢农场动物。能够在更灵活的意义上探索这一点
everything just by looking at it. She's amazing with that. So this is an alternative avenue that we're exploring that's much more appropriate for her. And I think that's something that's important when you're educating people with autism, that the mainstream and the typical way of sitting exams might not actually be appropriate and that's okay. It's fine to find something that works for them because chances are that they might not actually be able to work in the traditional sense anyway because that, in my sister's case anyway, that would be too overwhelming for her to cope with. So something where she can work with animals and her favourite being horses and she loves also she farm animals really. That's being able to explore that in a much more flexible sense
真是太棒了，而且太棒的是，经历了几乎充满创伤的教育之旅后，她现在处于一个可以真正专注于她感兴趣的事情并去追求它的阶段。是的，我喜欢这样，这太美妙了。事实上，你知道的，有很多关于马术治疗的文献、经验和案例研究，以及这实际上有多大帮助，所以也许这可以作为她疗愈的一部分，作为点亮她的生命的一部分。绝对是的，看看她在马背上时的变化。我姐姐有选择性缄默。所以通常如果我们外出到社区或在不熟悉的人周围，她不会说话。
is amazing and it's great that after the almost traumatic journey that she's been through of education that she's now at a stage where she can really focus on something she's interested in and she can just pursue that. Yeah I love that that's so nice and actually you know there's there's lots of kind of literature and experiences and case studies about equine therapy and actually how helpful that can be so maybe that's as part of her healing as part of what you know as well as part of what lights her up. Absolutely and to see the difference when she's on a horse. So my sister is selectively mute. So normally she won't talk if we're out in the community or around people she's not familiar with.
她试着用手语，但有时候手语也会让人不知所措，因为她不喜欢被注视的感觉。所以这可能很困难。但当她在马背上时，她会去进行野外骑乘等活动，她会向交通指挥，这绝对是太棒了。她能够向汽车和她不认识的人打手势并进行沟通。但如果她不在马背上，这就太多了，这不是她能做到的。但看到这种差异，知道她拥有这些技能，这只是取决于她能在什么语境下使用它们？这真是太惊人了，确实如此。
She tries to sign but sometimes signing can be overwhelming as well because she doesn't like to feel observed. So that can be difficult. But when she's on a horse, she will go out on hacks and things and she will signal to traffic and that's absolutely amazing. She's able to signal and to communicate to cars and people she doesn't know. But if she's not on a horse, it's too much and it's not something she's able to do. But to see that difference and knowing that she has these skills, it's just what context is she able to use them in? And it's, it's absolutely amazing. It really is.
是的，确实如此。我想这也让她思考想要保护那匹马，你知道的，让那匹马受到尊重并获得它所需要的空间，不要让交通太吵或太快，这真的在帮助她为自己以及为马匹据理力争。绝对是的，我认为动物对自闭症患者作为一种治疗手段的影响是绝对惊人的，这绝对是一个优势，如果你在支持一个自闭症患者，
Yeah, it really is. And I guess it's making her think about wanting to protect that horse and, you know, for that horse to be respected and given, you know, the, the, the room that it needs and not have the traffic be too noisy or too fast and it's really helping her to be assertive for herself but for the horse as well. Absolutely and that's something I think the impact of animals for people with autism as a therapeutic thing is absolutely amazing and it's definitely a strength and if you are supporting someone with autism
考虑它是否合适，让他们能够做并且参与与动物相关的事情可能会对他们有益。是的，我们今天没有时间详细展开，但我们将在未来的某一集里聚在一起，讨论自闭症的理论框架。你能简要地告诉我们人们可能会听到哪些理论吗？当然，如果你在学习障碍（LD）服务部门工作，或者你与自闭症患者一起工作，你可能会听到很多关于积极行为支持（PBS）的内容。这是在寻找大多具挑战性行为背后的含义。所以它们为什么会发生？它们试图传达什么？
thinking about whether it's appropriate, something that they can do and engage in with animals might be beneficial to them. Yeah, we haven't got time for it today but we are going to get together for a future episode thinking about the theoretical kind of frameworks for autism. Could you briefly just tell us what those are that people might hear about? Absolutely, so if you're working in an LD service or if you're working with people with autism, you might hear a lot about positive behaviour support. This is looking at the meaning behind mostly challenging behaviours. So why do they occur? What are they trying to communicate?
因为通常这是一种沟通方式。然后我们如何支持他们获得所需的东西，而不需要表现出具有挑战性或自残的行为？这与应用行为分析（ABA）直接形成对比，后者几乎完全相反。它着眼于尝试使用正强化和惩罚方法来减少具有挑战性的行为，并且完全忽视了其背后的含义可能是什么。因此，PBS是在ABA的基础上发展起来的，旨在克服其中一些问题，并且是一种更有同情心的观点。它通常与创伤知情护理结合使用，这非常非常重要
Because often it is a method of communication. And how then do we support them to get what they need without the need to be challenging or to self harm? It contrasts directly with applied behavioural analysis, which is almost the opposite. It looks at trying to use positive reinforcement and punishment methods to reduce challenging behaviours, and it's completely ignorant of what the meanings could be. So PBS was developed from ABA to kind of overcome some of these issues, and it's a much more compassionate view. It's normally used in combination with trauma-informed care, which is very, very important
在与神经多样性人群合作时，因为它能帮助你审视经历一个并非为你设计的世界所带来的所有创伤，以及你将因此面临的所有问题。在与神经多样性人群合作或交谈时，牢记这些事情非常非常非常重要。所以这就是我能对这些技术是什么给出的简要概述。
when working with neurodiverse people, because it helps you to look at all of the trauma associated with going through a world that's not designed for you and all of the problems that you will face because of that. And it's very, very important to keep these things in mind when working or talking with someone who is neurodiverse. So that's kind of the brief overview that I can give on what those techniques are.
希望这……谢谢。是的，确实如此。我们以后还会回过头来探讨。但是，你知道的，你显然知识渊博。你显然花了很多时间来了解这些事情，以便你能以最佳方式帮助你的姐姐，但也可能以最佳方式帮助你正在服务的客户。你目前作为一名助理心理学家（AP）在哪个领域、哪个群体中工作？所以我在
I hope that's... Thank you. Yeah, it does. And we will come back to it in future. But you know, you are clearly so knowledgeable. You've clearly spent a lot of time learning about these things so that you can optimally help your sister, but probably optimally help your clients in services that you're working with as well. Which area, which population are you working with as an AP currently? So I'm working
两个兼职的AP职位上工作，其中一个我在CAMHS与儿童一起工作，然后我也在成人学习障碍（LD）服务中工作。在这个职位上，我走访社会护理之家，我帮助支持那些可能在“如何支持患有学习障碍或自闭症的人”方面遇到问题的客户和员工，并努力培养这种富有同情心的态度，解决社会护理系统中一些更系统性的问题，以及我们如何在那种环境中支持这些人？嗯，我会说他们绝对找对了这份工作的人。你知道，听起来，你知道，你感觉真的很有安全感，真的。而且，你知道的，很好，充满同情心，你会希望这样的人去与你关心的人共事。
two part-time AP roles so I work within CAMS with children and then I also work within an adult LD service. Within that role I go to social care homes and I help support both clients and staff who might be experiencing issues with how do you support someone with a learning disability or autism and trying to foster that compassionate approach and work through some of those more systemic problems within the social care system and how do we support those people within that kind of environment? Well, I'd say they've definitely got the right person for that job. You know, you sound, you know, you know, you feel like a really safe pair of hands, really. But also, you know, nice, compassionate hands that you'd want someone to be working with someone that you care about as well.
所以干得好。我希望无论你现在还是将来申请博士学位，你都能在那里获得非常丰厚、实至名归的成功。非常感谢。我认为培养同情心非常重要，不仅对自闭症社群，对每个人都应如此。人与人之间有很多差异，但重要的是要保持同情心。这就是心理学的目标，去关爱他人。我不认为如果你不想帮助别人，你会进入这个领域。所以尽可能多地从那个充满同情心的角度看待问题，这就是我
So well done to you. I hope that whether it's your time to apply to doctorates now or in the future that you have really rich well-deserved success there. Thank you so much. I think it's so important to foster compassion, not just towards the autistic community, but towards everyone. There's so many differences between people, but it's important to just be compassionate. And that's what psychology aims to do, to care for others. And I don't think you'd be in this field if you didn't want to help people. So looking as much as you can from that compassionate point of view, that's what I
在所有事情上真正努力去做的事。如果我能给你的听众留下一个信息，那就是尽量表现出尽可能多的同情心。绝对是的。当这集节目播出时，我为有志心理学家建立的新网站将已经上线，但你知道的，在我的“关于我”板块中，我想它是说实际上同情心是多么重要，即使你从未买过一本书，如果你从未听过我的一集播客节目，请务必、务必拥抱，拥抱你知道的同情心和以同情心为焦点的疗法，为你自己和你身边的人，因为这会改变生活。
really try to do with everything. And if that's if there's one message that I can leave your listeners with it would just be to try and be as compassionate as possible. Absolutely and my new website for aspiring psychologists will have launched by the time this episode goes out but you know in my about me section I think it is it's kind of saying actually how important compassion is and even if you never buy a book, if you never listen to a podcast episode by me, please, please embrace, embrace you know compassion and compassion-focused therapy and for yourself and those that you're with because it is life-changing.
绝对是的。非常感谢你抽出时间，汉娜，并向我推荐这集节目。希望这还可以。我们会为下一集预定一个日期的。非常感谢。这是一次非常非常振奋人心、有用的对话。太棒了。非常感谢邀请我来。哦，不用谢。谢谢你来。哦，非常感谢我们今天的嘉宾汉娜。她的洞察力、她的热情、她的准备工作真的深深打动了我。多棒的一集节目，多棒的一位嘉宾啊。所以谢谢汉娜，我祝愿你的职业生涯未来一切顺利。你想给我推荐一集节目吗？
Absolutely. Thank you so much for your time Hannah and for pitching this episode to me. I hope it's been okay. We will get a date booked in for that next episode. Thank you so much. It's been a really, really invigorating, useful conversation. That's great. Thank you so much for having me. Oh, you're so welcome. Thank you for coming. Oh, thank you so much for our guest today Hannah. She just blew me away with her insight, her passion, her preparedness you know. What a great episode, what a great guest. So thank you Hannah and I am hopeful for you for whatever your career brings next. Would you like to pitch me an episode
为有志心理学家播客投稿吗？请务必来社交媒体上与我联系。那是向我推荐节目的最简单的地方。汉娜是通过领英（LinkedIn）向我推荐的。你为什么不也这样做呢？到处都是玛丽安·特伦特博士（Dr. Marianne Trent）。如果你在寻找关于如何反思的灵感，也许是如何将自己看作是一个
for the Aspiring Psychologist podcast? Please do come and connect with me on socials. That's the easiest place to pitch me your episodes. Hannah pitched me via LinkedIn. Why don't you do the same? I'm Dr. Marianne Trent Everywhere. If you're looking for some inspiration on how to reflect, perhaps how to see yourself as an
自闭症心理健康专业人士，请务必查看《自闭症文集》（An Autistic Anthology），这是一本于2024年11月出版的书，当然，有关临床心理学的更多一般性经验，请查看《有志心理学家集体》（The Aspiring Psychologist Collective）和《临床心理学家集体》（The Clinical Psychologist Collective）。如果时机成熟，你已经准备好迈出下一步，并且希望为你的职业生涯在研究、认知行为疗法、反思实践、自信心方面获得一些指导，你知道，克服冒名顶替综合症，并让它消失，以帮助你自信地掌控自己的职业生涯。请务必查看有志心理学家会员计划（the aspiring psychologist membership），你只需每月30英镑起即可加入，且没有最低期限要求。但如果你确实想长期加入，有一些
autistic mental health professional, please do check out An Autistic Anthology, which is a book that was published in November 2024, or of course for more general experiences of clinical psychology, check out The Aspiring Psychologist Collective and The Clinical the clinical psychologist collective too. If it's your time and you're ready for the next step and you want some guidance for your career around research, around cognitive behavioral therapy, around reflective practice, around confidence, you know taking that imposter syndrome and you know making it be banished to help you to confidently take control of your career. Do check out the aspiring psychologist membership which you can join from just £30 a month with no minimum term. But if you did want to join for a longer term there are
优惠活动可以让你免费获得与我一对一交流的时间。这有什么不好的呢？请务必访问我的网站，在那里你可以获取我的免费心理学成功指南。我的全新网站是 www.aspiring-psychologist.co.uk。那是新鲜出炉的。我今天才刚和我的网站编辑开会敲定它。所以你可能已经在我的社交媒体上看到了，但这是我第一次能够在我的播客录音中提到它。所以请务必来看看。来看看并告诉我你的看法。我很想听听你的反馈。非常感谢你成为我世界的一部分。快来加入免费的Facebook群组——由玛丽安·特伦特博士创立的有志心理学家社群（the Aspiring Psychologist Community with Dr. Marianne Trent）。获得资格认证就是有志心理学家播客
incentives around which get you one-to-one time with me for free. What's not to like there? Please do come along to my website where you can access my free psychology success guide. My brand new website is www.aspiring-psychologist.co.uk. That is hot off the press. I only met with my website editor today to get that signed off. So you might already have seen that on my social media, but this is the first time I've been able to mention it in my podcast recording. So please do come along. Come and check it out. Let me know what you think to it. I would love your feedback. Thank you so much for being part of my world. Come and join the free Facebook group, the Aspiring Psychologist Community with Dr. Marianne Trent. Being qualified is the aspiring psychologist podcast
与玛丽安·特伦特博士 本集节目暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。
With Dr. Mary entrance There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
随着玛丽医生的加入，本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。